Would you want a Kadafi or an Arafad or Castro
to be a future president of South Africa?
One of the mistakes
which has some political and,
and others make
is to think that their enemies should be our enemies,
that
we can and we will never do.
We have our own struggle which we're conducting.
We are grateful to the world
for supporting our struggle.
But nevertheless,
we are an independent organisation with its own policy.
And the attitude of every country towards our
attitude towards any country is determined by the
attitude of that country to our struggle.
Colonel Gaddafi,
Fidel Castro
support our struggle to the hilt.
There is no reason whatsoever
why we should have any hesitation about healing
their commitment to human rights
as they are being demanded in South Africa.
Our attitude is based solely
on the fact that they fully support
the anti apartheid struggle.
They do not support it only in rhetoric.
They are placing resources at our disposal for us.
So when to stop
that is the position.
Having said that,
I think I would be dishonest
if I did not express profound disappointment
with the answer that Mister Mandela gave to
the previous question,
because it suggests a certain degree of immorality. The,
it suggests that the,
what these people do in their own countries,
what a cadafi does in Libya, what it,
what a Castro does in Cuba
is totally irrelevant,
even in terms of the issue of,
of human Rights
as long as they support the cause of the ANC.
I hope that is not what Mister Mandela meant
and I would hope that he
would clarify that issue further.
Mister Mandela,
and at the same time
want me to be involved in the internal affairs of Libya
and uh a Cuba.
I refuse to do that.
As far as Yassa Arafat is concerned,
I explained it to Mister Sydney
that we identify with the P&O
because just like ourselves,
they are fighting for the right of self determination.
I went further, however,
to say that the support
for Yassa Arafat in his struggle
does not mean that the ANC has ever doubted
the right of Israel to exist as a state. Legally,
we have stood quite open and family
for the right of that state to exist
within secured borders.
But of course,
as I said to Mister Signal in Geneva and others
that we carefully define what we mean by secure body.
We do not mean that uh Israel has the right to retain
the territories they conquered from the Arab world,
like the Gaza Street,
the Golan Heights and the West Bank.
We don't agree with that.
Those territories should be returned to the Arab people.
Mister Mandela,
I also explained to Mr Sigmund and company
that in our organisation we have Jews. In fact,
Mr Gadaf did not allow us to open our offices in Libya
precisely because we had the courage to say to him
We work with Jews in our organisation,
and he didn't allow us to open an office
until February this year,
when he had it to accept us as we are.
We are not prepared to be saved by anybody.
We have an independent policy
which we are certain,
no matter with whom we discuss.
The Jewish leader have any doubts about our stand,
I am prepared to address them and to allay
at their concern,
because they are a very important community,
both in South Africa and, of course,
in the States.
And I'm prepared
to iron out any differences that might exist.
But they must know what our stand is.
Arafat is a comrade in arm.
And retreat in a sec.
And as I have said,
we have many Jews,
members of the Jewish community in our struggle,
and they have occupied very top positions.
But that does not mean to say
that the enemies of Israel are our enemies.
We refuse to take that position.
You can call it being political or a moral question,
but for anybody
which changes his principles,
depending on whom he is dealing,
that is not a man who can lead a nation.